-When we come back,
we're going to talk about
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife."
More with Bill Murray,
Dan Aykroyd, Ernie Hudson!
Come on back!
♪♪
-♪ In the cool of the evening ♪
♪ When everything is
feelin' kind of groovy ♪
♪ And I call you up and ask you
if you want to come and
come and see a movie ♪
♪ Well, first, you say "no" ♪
♪ You got plans for the night ♪
♪ And then you stop
and say "alright" ♪
♪ Oh, kinda spooky ♪
♪ With a spooky
little girl like you, yeah ♪
Go, go, go, go!
-♪ Spooky ♪
-♪ Spooky, yeah ♪
-♪ Girl like you ♪
-♪ Spooky, spooky ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, now,
you always keep me guessin' ♪
♪ I never seem to know
what you are thinkin' ♪
♪ And when you see a guy,
I know your little eye
will be a-winkin' ♪
-♪ I said, lonely ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ First, you say no,
you got plans for the night ♪
♪ And then and say,
"Well, alright" ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, with a crazy
spooky little girl
like you, yeah ♪
-♪ Spooky ♪
-♪ Yeah, spooky ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ Spooky, yeah ♪
-♪ Uh-huh, uh-huh, spooky ♪
♪ Spooky, spooky, spooky ♪
♪ You spooky, you spooky
little girl ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
[ Scatting ]
-We're gonna come back.
♪♪
-♪ Spooky little girl like you ♪
-Oh, my goodness. Come on, now!
That's Bill. Come on!
Dan Aykroyd!